[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview nos
deux invités deux figures majeures de la
lutte contre la copie de 19 à au sénégal
a d'abord le professeur moussa s'est dit
chef du service des maladies
infectieuses à l'hôpital de fann à dakar
la capitale responsable de la prise en
charge de tous les malades
au sénégal et puis nous rejoindront le
docteur abdoulaye bousso directeur du
centre des opérations d'urgence
sanitaire est également expert à l'om
est ce professeur said i bonjour bonjour
alors pourquoi vous maintenez le
traitement à base d'hydroquinone rockin
et d'asie trop micinn pour soigner les
malades dans votre pays malgré la
polémique mondiale sur l'efficacité de
cette combinaison nous avons notre
résultat qui dit notre paiement
au début nous étions basés sur les
résultats préliminaires ne peut
s'habiller en rouge et ceux d'autres
arguments
tu n'es pas un tel que des cliquez ici
mais ensuite nous avions plus la
décision de novalis résultats du premier
tour et liminaire avait montré que cette
association était efficace du diet au
réveil la deuxième sur un plus grand
nombre de morts et qui a concerné c'est
150 patients dont 498 patients âgés de
plus de 12 ans a également confirmé
cette efficacité et cette bonne
tolérance aucun des patients qui avaient
dressé leurs combinaisons avait eu de
complication et fait virer la durée
médiane de guérison a été enregistré
cinq jours il n'y avait pas de
secondaire majeur
on avait juste douze événements
indésirables après secondaire ce qui
posait une proportion de deux pour cent
des patients et les effets secondaires
en tout cas d'occuper heures de 8 % des
patients et aucun effet secondaire
l'intégrale ses effets secondaires
n'avait pas les traitements
supplémentaires d'augmentation de la
durée d'hospitalisation est plus aisé
avec l'espagne est là et luton est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
sur ses effets secondaires
auxquels vous faites allusion les effets
secondaires que nous avons observé y en
avait 12 y avait quatre effets
secondaires qui était constitué de
diarrhées et de vomissements
donc c'est parce qu'un ont dû continuer
le traitement sans l'arrêter
la diarrhée les vomissements kilibo
n'est pas que du temps c'était super
liés à l'éco missiles nous avons eu
quatre effets secondaires qui était lié
à la cible d'intrus but c'était les
patients qui étaient allergiques à
l'usure projet inique mais qu'il ne
savait pas et avec quatre patients qui
avaient des troupes de démo carnot
vasculaire compassion à une palpitation
carrière un autre patient et braga de
vie un autre patient et académies
impatience des extrasystoles populaire
depuis combien de temps vous vous
traiter les malades du coronavirus avec
ce protocole est ce que c'est un délai
suffisant pour tirer des conclusions
positives il à vis de l'usaj de ce
traitement entre le leader noir si nous
avions démarré à l'explosif parce que
nous voulons éviter d'ajouter l'associé
de médicaments associés 2010 commençait
à ceux-ci de vie l'effet secondaire
après avoir fait une centaine de
patients le temps devant nous avons
décidé d'associer leurs originale à
cette commission
donc depuis le temps dimanche nous avons
commencé à faire cette association
alors nous n'avons pas tiré de
conclusion définitive nous avons fait du
périmètre 161 patients à journaux qui
chutent 559 passion et maintenant nous
allons faire un essai clinique randomisé
festival des maristes mois donc nous
faisons nos offres et c est à partir de
cette paix c'est nous qui le rend une
conclusion définitive parce que il faut
il faut le dire clairement
toutes les études n'ont pas la même
valeur cherche l'étude randomisée en
double aveugle et les fidèles
malheureusement ça nous pasteur il n'y a
aucune étude de ce type au monde qu'elle
est faite par rapport à cette maladie et
y en aura
ça c'était ce qui est passionnant de
musée c'est un beau
plus fier nous continuons j'ai fait des
évaluations intermédiaires été ou est ce
que nous devons continuer en attendant
le fric et c'est fini je peux vous dire
n'aime pas cela au début avec les
attentes et parce que nous avions pensé
que les ducks chloroquine poser la
différence avec l'absence de traitement
mais dans la deuxième série
cette différence était devenu assez mis
ce qui fait que nous avions bien fait de
démarrer l'association aude et le 30
mars est comme gelée j on savait déjà
depuis le début de la séance était plus
efficace mais c'est par prudence nous
avions commencé juste alors je leur ai
dit que si on trouve que les deux clubs
qui ne marche pas du tout nous ça ne
nous étonnera pas ce que nous avons de
toute façon quand ça fait que
l'association qui marche le plus c'est
alors commencer la décision de choisir
de cette option de traitement a été
prise au plus haut niveau vous avez joué
un rôle prépondérant
oui en fait comme on était un peu dans
le camp des bleus jean ça n'est qu'hier
je me suis dit que les médicaments
agissent et au niveau du biologie au
lavo rapport avec les publications
il y allait tous les yaourts et montre
que ça pouvait marcher une heure ça
c'est évident nous avons constaté que
cette molécule active disponible n'était
pas coûteuse et bien colère par rapport
à tous ces facteurs nous avons trouvé
plus logique démarrer le traitement mais
de le faire finalement un milieu
hospitalier avec plus de précaution
chaque patient doit bénéficier de notre
gamme de dans les deux villes très
rapprochées et cela nous a aidés à ne
pas avoir concédé gars les hawks
chloroquine la chloroquine de manière
géniale et a été utilisé en abuse
décennies et des décennies un médicament
très comique et ça comme un père sourire
les sénégalais quand j'entends je dis
les autres sinon je fais un point un
élément essentiel bien toutes les
équipes nécessaires
ce sont des études qu'on ne pouvait rien
mens pas comparer avec général avec
notre rôle de diana l'étude couvre
liquéfié peut-être intéressant que dans
ces tiges
le premier jour ils donnent aux quatre
fois supérieure à celle préconisée dans
la société générale
quand vous donnez le 4 avril si vous
avez les abonnés vous ne pouvez pas
continuer et comparer avait
judicieusement huit sangliers abattus
dénis personnalité les fauves peur du
changement
les lieux de l'intervention d'un
différend est né il ya un biais de
sélection par enfant est malade et sugar
on lève et se développe selon lequel
agissent aussi pour pouvoir dire après
que cette association puis le mal à l'om
mais sachez que le traitement ne réduit
pas justement la mortalité chez les
patients hospitalisés selon plusieurs
études
comment vous réagissez - cette
conclusion le malien vous vous souvenez
de la fiq le lancet
c'est un article de l'escroquerie
scientifiquement c'est comme ça que
j'aime l'appeler il est évident admet 6
sur la base de cette la france a décidé
d'arrêter là tellement que l'oms a
suspendu de manière france et pas en
bourse pour railler mais ce qu'on peut
comprendre une institution
internationale reste prudente
donc nous sommes des scientifiques au
même titre que ces gens qui écrivent
nous n'allons pas suivre comme des
moutons de panurge je sais qu'il dit ça
et là et il faut rappeler que dans le
protocole de m
mais aussi croire qu'ils n'aient pas
évolué de la même manière dans la foule
de détails mais il ne faut pas comparer
le résultat original des dialogues ou
chiffre celui de la roja schumi n'est
pas voilà deux choses comparables avant
qu'on ne puisse les comparer vous le
connaissez le professeur didier rahout
c'est quasiment un enfant du pays ces
travaux sont suivis de près on imagine
au sénégal est ce qu'il est influent ici
est ce que vous le connaissez on pouvait
la vérité vous pouvez lui poser la
question ne s'est jamais vu on ne sait
jamais parlé je le savais même pas qu'il
avait des liens avec ben c'est bien je
connais cette équipe et je sais que
certains grands chercheurs
je sais que c'est quelqu'un qui est
passionné par son travail je suis un peu
kiffer voilà c'était le monde
scientifique
les intérêts sur le quoi qu'on dise ne
sont pas aussi nombreux festivals les
milieux spécialisés restent sèches merci
on se bat a publiquement reconnu à
travers leurs écrits
donc il ya pas une influence quelconque
de telle ou telle personne je les lis et
répéter si le virus le comportement ne
nourrissent pas changé au fil du temps
le confirmant le virage vis-à-vis des
médicaments peut changer je voulais dire
aujourd'hui réunies trans neige avec la
prairie 1 et occupent leur kiné absence
de sept mois en chine
quand la série a augmenté cette
différence est devenu moins le bon
heureusement que nous on avait déjà pris
le parti de faire l'association depuis
longtemps je trouve que l'association
n'est pas que je dirais oui voilà ce que
j'ai trouvé leur scolarité mais ça ne
marche pas dans les cas graves
ça ne peut pas faire plus de mal
d'accord mais ça ne marche pas et dans
ce débat qui divise la communauté
scientifique on le voit avez vous le
sentiment que votre positionnement celui
des pays africains n'est pas assez
considéré prises en compte
non je moi je ne vois pas les choses
ainsi
je pense que les gens n'ont pas de date
est ce que nous nous faisons ou c'est
non il faut voir ce que l'on festoie
mais nous ne sommes qu'à part nous avons
les patients nous sommes capables de
faire les études et même laissé dans
l'essai clinique dont je vous parle on
essaie de le faire avec l'espace et de
dakar et qui est un décès au niveau de
filtrage lahoun non résolus mais je sais
au monde donc nous avons la capacité
nous avons les compétences nous avons
les moyens de faire les études comme les
autres dont un qu'il n'y aura pas de
consensus au niveau international nous
nous passerons tous n'ont pas hésité à
avancer
je pense que cette épidémie de cofidis 2
met mal à l'aise la communauté
scientifique
voilà très mal à l'aise ça ça montre
qu'on ne connaît pas aussi intègres
après un essai et villa s'agissant de la
pandémie
elle semble progresser assez rapidement
maintenant en afrique est ce que vous
vous craignez une flambée des cas dans
votre pays oui moi j'ai l'habitude de
dire que les sens du baas et informe
ainsi que le plus important ce sont les
ché voilà je crois que en tout état de
cause dans l équilibre doit toujours
préparés se préparer au pire c'est en se
préparant il qu'on peut faire face mais
est-ce que ça va évoluer dans un sens ou
dans un autre
ça dépend de beaucoup de facteurs parmi
lesquels le comportement de la
communauté et ce comportement là vous ne
pouvez pas toujours le maîtriser il y
avait les technos qui circulent un peu
partout
voilà c'est quand on ne sait pas il faut
avoir de l'humilité des décors sais pas
comment ça va évoluer
on ne le sait pas si les gens restent
que tous les mots justes à va très bien
se passer
on va s'en sortir avec beaucoup moins de
l'essec en euros ça j'en suis convaincu
mais si les gens ne pensent qu il
n'existe pas alors à savoir ce qui va
arriver
merci beaucoup professeur s'est dit pour
cette grande interview sourire de franz
bon courage à vous on va poursuivre dans
un instant avec le docteur abdoulaye
bousso directeur du centre des
opérations d'urgence sanitaire au
sénégal assez juste après une courte
pause athlètes
[Musique]
retour dans la grande interview on
continue d'évoquer la lutte contre la
copie de 10,9 au sénégal avec le dr
abdoulaye bousso bonjour docteur bonjour
alors vous êtes expert de l'om est ce
vous dirige également le centre des
opérations d'urgence sanitaire au
sénégal à quelle est votre mission
notre mission d'action des opérations du
lion de ciani thc de coordonner les
événements de briques de portée
nationale ou internationale est donc
actuellement dans le cadre de cette
épidémie comme une pizza au sénégal
située en charge de la coordination
opérationnelle dans tout le pays l'om
est ce encore stopper ces essais
cliniques solides roxy chloroquine pour
la deuxième fois depuis la publication
de l'étude de l'ancêtre est ce qu'on
peut faire confiance à l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
bien sûr on peut faire confiance à
l'organisation de la localisation par
les états de la santé mais aussi que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé à
certaines considérations qu'elle est
obligée de prendre en compte
après les pays sont tout à fait libres
et autonomes de prendre les décisions ça
vont évoluer les protocoles les
procédures de traitement qui sont
actuellement en cours et si les
décisions nous les prendrons toute
liberté en toute
en tout cas basé sur des faits
scientifiques elle enfin que le sénégal
comme le maroc ou l'algérie maintient le
protocole du dr didier rahout ça veut
dire quand même qu il ya des divergences
entre les états le sénégal est
le ms oui en fait nous ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que nous avions déjà
commencé à utiliser le protocole avec
des trucs bien avant que le ms ne
commencent à s'en lécher
donc quand le sénégal a commencé le ms a
fait appel aux pays qui pour nous c'est
un impôt toile qui a commencé depuis
plusieurs semaines et pour lequel nous
n'aurons pas de problème particulier
nous avons actuellement une 68 % de taux
de guérison on va pas dire que tout est
lié aux résultats que nous avons il n'y
a pas de signes qui mettra en doute les
deux cas c'est de ce protocole notre
taux de mortalité la létalité
aujourd'hui aveugle 3%
donc ceci n'est confort et nous avons
aussi pas de complications ni d'effets
secondaires majeurs et donc je commence
je vous parle on sait que le ms a alerté
fasse une possible catastrophe sanitaire
en afrique en tout cas la pandémie elle
progresse quand même sur le continent
c'est ce qu'on peut observer quelles
sont les informations à votre niveau
oui tout à fait c'est vrai que tant la
pandémie a touché l'europe les états
unis on s'attendait à ce que qu'enfin
tout cela fait que les choses aillent de
manière très négative ce qui n'est pas
le cas ce qui n'est pas encore le cas en
tout cas je pense que les pays comme en
afrique un euro je pense qu'on ait des
leçons des différents des différents
événements de sont plus des différents
événements de simples qui ils sont
passés continent ils ont permis un peu
de faire face mais également aussi la
plupart des pays comme le nôtre au
sénégal
des mesures ont été prises très tôt pour
essayer de contenir cette épidémie pour
le moment en tout cas les chiffres
montrent que même si l'épidémie encore
en cours au sénégal l'épidémie en cours
mais par rapport aux prévisions
nous sommes très loin de ses prévisions
pensons vraiment en continu à ces
mesures de contingence pouvoir arriver à
je pense que tous les pays africains et
parlez-nous plus en détail de la
situation
au sénégal donc pour le sénégal
aujourd'hui nous avons une létalité qui
à mon sens nous avait son petit pourcent
des guérisons dépit de vie est quand
même sur tout le pays nous avions 14
régions dans ce pays et sur l'ensemble
des régions
au moins un cas a été notifié pour le
moment nous avons l'épicentre de
l'épidémie au niveau de la région de
dakar qui est la capitale ce qui se
comprend bien capital qui pendent parce
que son époux cent de la population du
sénégal et dans notre région qui est la
région de thiès qui a ce sont uniquement
de dakar et la région de diourbel dakar
pour le mémoire nous avions quand même a
toujours des cas une contamination qui
active et sur laquelle aujourd'hui nous
essaierons de faire surtout impliquant
la communauté parce qu'aujourd'hui ce
qui va être plus important c'est de
pouvoir mettre fin à cette transmission
et pour nous c'est la communauté qui
doit être à travers le respect des
musiques variées
l'état d'urgence est instauré depuis le
23 mars dernier au sénégal il a provoqué
des émeutes en cause notamment le
couvre-feu qui est imposé aux
populations est ce que les autorités
sont allées trop loin dans les mesures
de restriction non pas du tout je pense
qu'on l'a vu tout à l'heure que et des
mesures qui ont été prises très tôt et
qui ont permis d'endiguer un peu
l'évolution de cette épidémie dans les
plantations on partait sur au moins
trois fois le nombre de cas nous avons
donc ces mesures ont servi ses démesures
lequel nous sommes professionnels de la
santé nous avons conseillé l'autorité
enfin maintenant on s'est un peu rêveur
après deux mois d'entraînement sociaux
commencé à se dégrader
et aussi je pense que maintenant on a
une meilleure compréhension de la
maladie ce qui fait que le discours
actuellement ces dix jours avec la
maladie mais ne le sont pas sûrs que les
virus les autorités ont allégé le
couvre-feu les restrictions dans les
transports notamment quels sont les
risques maintenant
aujourd'hui c'est vrai il ya allées de
circulation parce qu'il y avait un
continent surtout en pleine région n'y
avait pas de possibilité de faire un
déplacement entre les régions du pays
aujourd'hui les sénégalais a mis les
écoles vont bientôt ouvrir normalement
le 25 juin
le risque est là le risque de diffusion
de la maladie mais n'empêche comme nous
le lisons depuis le départ ce qui est
important c'est le respect des musiques
barry comme on dit le port de masques la
distanciation physique des jeunes demain
aujourd'hui la le programme obligatoire
dans les allées des publics et dans les
transports donc c'est quelque chose
aussi qui va beaucoup aider à limiter
ses transmissions et je pense qu'ils ont
tout d'accord aujourd'hui qu'on ne peut
pas continuer à nous qu'on finit il faut
qu'on apprend vraiment à vivre avec
cette maladie
parce que comme je dis nous savons
comment la contamination se fait et on
voit que si on respecte les mesures
barrières on peut arriver là m il ya
assez de masques de gel hydro alcoolique
au sénégal oui c'est à cette épidémie a
suscité beaucoup de générosité de la
part des sénégalais aujourd'hui le colis
qui sont fabriqués par pendant nos
universités nos écoles d'ingénieurs qui
en fabriquant un quotidien de celles
menant au niveau des masses qui à
l'artisanat local clichés qui s'est mis
à fabriquer des masques donc extrêmement
important c'est fabrication de masse qui
ont été encadrés à travers des normes
bien précises qui concourt aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya la pollution de
masse effet à grande échelle par l'état
sénégalais à tous les niveaux et dans
toutes les régions donc oui on va dire
était déjà là assez assez mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui toutes les personnes qui
voudraient la voir très facilement il ya
beaucoup aussi de soutien de la part des
communiqués des communautés de certaines
organisations qui font des dons à
masquer aux populations vous parlez des
communautés
est ce que les populations c'est que
l'aspect culturel est très important au
sénégal l'aspect religieux aussi est ce
que les populations respecte bien ces
mesures barrières oui il ya quand même
et l'engagement des populations
maintenant c'est vrai que c'est à des
niveaux différents si vous voulez parler
d'engagement par rapport aux communautés
aux religieux s'ils tombent tous un
exemple quand l'autorisation a été
donnée aux d'ouvrir les lieux de culte
beaucoup de mosquées ont décidé de ne
pas ouvrir les rues parce qu'ils ont
pensé qu' après ils ont constaté qu'il
n'y avait pas toutes les conditions pour
pouvoir oublier les mosquées les mêmes
que l'église pouvoir les vivre donc oui
il ya un engagement communautaire bon
même si quand même on note un petit
relâchement et surtout par rapport aux
populations on peut dire aujourd'hui que
dans le cadre de notre du profil
épidémiologique au sénégal plus de 60% a
cédé personnes asymptomatiques qui sont
généralement je n'ai donc ces personnes
souvent il ya quand même quelques cas
pense que même si je ne m'abuse n'existe
pas mais a quand même la majorité de la
population adhère et nous continuer à
faire cette sensibilisation la situation
dans les hôpitaux de votre pays dans
quelles conditions également évolué
travail les personnels de soins de santé
oui en fait une une stratégie a été dès
le départ de cons en chage l'ancien
toute personne positive était à chapelle
résilience de notre système de santé
tous les patients qui sont pris en
charge dans les unités de traitement si
des élus t qui n'empêche pas l'activité
de l'hôpital donc ce qui fait que même
si bien sûr il ya quand même une baisse
de la fréquentation des deux hôpitaux
par les patients on a vu une certaine
crainte des des sénégalais en général à
50 et les soucis de santé mais ça m'a
pas du tout du tout les malades vous
avez loupé en citant des sources
hospitalières au début quand un certain
niveau
demain assez important nous avons mis en
place ce qu'on appelle des sites de
prise en charge
extra hospitaliers donc qui pourrait des
hôtels des centres d'accueil que nous
avons aménagé mis en place avec une
équipe médicale deux ambulances
médicalisées pour prendre en charge ces
personnes est donc aujourd'hui le
personnel est engagée sur les sites des
tènements et que je fasse tout allié au
niveau des cds ternir hospitalier et a
aussi un engagement à les protéger parce
qu'on voit quand même qu'il ya souvent
un risque important pour ces personnes
de 2,5 était aujourd'hui nous tournons
autour de 140 personnels de son affectés
dont certains sont affectés dans la
communauté doute dans les à l'hôpital
mais au moins je reconnais que nous
n'avons pas de a effecté dans le site de
prix de recharge comme une spécialité
pour venir aux populations avec les
restrictions comment les sénégalais font
face aux besoins de première nécessité
l'axé par exemple à l'eau potable et aux
denrées alimentaires on n'a pas fait un
contenu identique au sénégal
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'était
surtout le court le couteau au départ
qui partait de 21h à 6h du matin qui a
été allégé qui est maintenant de 3 à 5
heures du matin
donc toute la journée les sénégalais
avait l'habitude d'aller au marché et
deux en course donc il n'y a pas
vraiment eu de l'obstacle parfois cela
il y avait au départ une petite
réception des marchés mais pas besoin
d'un bouc à à pouvoir trouver de
l'aliment de l'autre sénat il n'y a pas
de difficultés particulières n'en
contient que sur le plan beaucoup
d'activités qui ont été à un parti et
qui font que sur le plan économique
forcément les populations ressenti
l'effet de ce que vous parlez des
communautés tout à l'heure les certaines
victimes de lakovic 19 leurs familles
font face à un roger dans certaines
communautés quelles sont les
conséquences de cette stigmatisation qui
tâche il ya une stigmatisation qui est
actuellement en cours et nous étions
vraiment de cette utilisation
et je pense est aussi dû à cette
hypermédiatisation de 7
de cette maladie au départ là moi même
j'en arrive dans le pays avec toutes les
images que nous voyons à de l'autre côté
du continent des images de cirque d
hiver de réanimation rempli et donc ça
crée une peur un peu au niveau des
populations et entraîner un peu cette
stigmatisation des personnes qui étaient
atteints et donc c'est sûr
qu'aujourd'hui notre combat c'est un peu
de pouvoir arrêter cette validation et
je pense que de plus en plus les gens se
rendent compte que c'est une maladie
comme les autres
la mortalité aujourd'hui en tout cas
pour le sénégal de ce qu'on vide n'est
pas important et un butoir pour cent
nous avons dans le pays d'autres
maladies qui tuent plus est aujourd'hui
10e qui donne confiance aux populations
c'est aussi le taux de guérison qui as
est important c'est qu'ils ont moins que
les comprendre aux gens que on peut
tomber malade et c'est cette guérite
donc nous jouons un peu sur ces leviers
en main tremblements l'accent suis là
c'est l'engagement communautaire sur
l'implication des chefs religieux des
femmes des associations pour ne pouvoir
me faire un peu à cette machination
merci beaucoup à vous docteur abdoulaye
bousso rappelle que vous êtes expert de
l' oms directeur du centre des
opérations d'urgence sanitaire au
sénégal merci à vous et puis également
au professeur moussa sévit avec qui nous
étions tout à l'heure infectiologue à
l'hôpital de fann à dakar en charge de
malades de lakovic 19 au sénégal merci à
vous et merci de l'avoir suivi cette
grande interview une grande interview
que vous pouvez retrouver sur nos
réseaux sociaux en podcast sur rt france
point tva très bientôt
[Musique]